we were talking about motherhood like
part of the reason i'm so late because i
had to get the baby to bed um and it's
like i keep thinking about motherhood
how um under capitalism
it's like this extremely essential job
that is very difficult that is not
compensated and we sort of like value
things by by how much we
compensate them and so we really devalue
motherhood in our society and pretty
much all societies like capitalism does
not recognize motherhood it's just a job
that you're supposed to do for free
um and it's like but i feel like
producing
great humans should be seen as a great
as a as profit under capitalism like
that should be that's like a huge social
good like every
awesome human that gets made adds so
much to the world so like if that was
integrated into the profit structure
then
um
you know and if we potentially found a
way to compensate motherhood so
come up with a compensation that's much
broader than just money
or or
it could just be money like what if you
just made
i don't know but i but i don't know how
you'd pay for that like i mean
that's where you start getting
into reallocation of resources that
people get
uh upset over well like what if we made
like a motherhood dao
yeah yeah
you know and and and um
you know used it to fund
like single mothers like
you know
pay for
making
babies
so i mean if you create and put
beautiful things onto the world that
could be
companies that can be bridges they could
be
art they could be a lot of things and
that could be children
which are
or education or anything that could
should be valued by society and that
should be somehow incorporated into the
framework of what
as a market
of what like if you contribute children
to this world that should be valued and
respected and uh sort of celebrated
like proportional to what it is which is
it's it's the thing that fuels human
civilization yeah like kind of important
i feel like everyone's always saying i
mean i think we're in very different
social spheres but everyone's always
saying like dismantle capitalism and i'm
like well okay well i don't think the
government should own everything like i
don't think we should not have private
ownership like that's scary you know
like that starts getting into weird
stuff and just sort of like i feel
there's almost no way to do that without
a police state you know yeah um
but obviously capitalism has some major
flaws um and i think actually mac uh
intro showed me this idea called social
capitalism which is a form of capitalism
that just like
considers social good to be uh also
profit like you know it's like right now
companies need to like you're supposed
to grow every quarter or whatever to
like show that you're
functioning well but it's like okay well
what if you kept the same
amount of profit you're still in the
green but then you have also all the
social good like do you really need all
this extra economic growth or could you
add this social good and that counts and
you know
i i don't know if i i am not an
economist i have no idea how this could
be achieved but i don't think economists
know how anything can be achieved either
but they pretend it's the thing they
construct a model and they they go on tv
shows and sound like an expert uh that's
the definition of economist
um how did
being a mother becoming a mother changes
a human being
would you say
man i think it kind of changed
everything and it's still changing me a
lot it's actually changing me more right
now in this moment than it was before
like today like this just like they get
in the
most recent months and stuff
can you elucidate that
child
chain like when you wake up in the
morning and you look at yourself it's
again which who are you
um how have you become different would
you say
i think it's just really real orienting
my priorities
and at first i was really fighting
against that because i somehow felt it
was like a failure of feminism or
something like i felt like it was like
bad if like my kids
started mattering more than my work um
and then like more recently i started
sort of analyzing that
uh thought in myself and being like
that's also kind of a construct it's
like we've just devalued motherhood so
much in our culture that like i feel
guilty for
caring
about my kids more than i care about my
work so feminism includes breaking out
of whatever the construct is
so yeah continually breaking it's like
freedom
empower you to be free and that means uh
but but it also but like being a mother
like i'm so much more creative like i
cannot believe
the massive amount of great brain growth
that i why do you think that is just
cause like the stakes are higher somehow
i think it's like
it's just so trippy watching
yeah consciousness emerge it's just like
it's like going on a crazy
journey or something it's like the
craziest science fiction
novel you could ever read it's just so
crazy watching consciousness
come into being and then at the same
time
like you're forced to
value your time
so much like when i have creative time
now it's so sacred i need to like
be really freaking
on it
um but the other thing is that uh
um
i used to just be like a cynic and i
used to just wanna like my last album
was called misanthropicine and it was
like this like
it was like a study in villainy like or
like it was like well what if you know
we have instead of the old gods we have
like new gods and it's like
misanthropicity is like misanthrope like
and anthropocene which is like the you
know
like and she's the goddess of climate
change or whatever it's like destroying
the world and it was just like
it was like dark and it was like a study
in villainy and it was sort of just like
like i used to like have no problem just
making cynical
angry scary art
um and now that there's anything wrong
with that but i think having kids just
makes you such an optimist it just
inherently makes you want to be an
optimist so bad that like um like i feel
like a more responsibility to
make more optimistic
things and
i get a lot of [ __ ] for it because
everyone's like
oh you're so privileged stop talking
about like pie in the sky stupid
concepts and focus on like the now but
it's like
um
i think if we don't ideate about um
futures that could be good we won't be
able to get them if everything is blade
runner then we're gonna end up with
blade runner it's like as
we said earlier life imitates art like
life really does imitate art and so
we really need more protopian or utopian
art um i think this is incredibly
essential for
the future of humanity and i think the
uh the current discourse where
um that's seen as a
thinking about
protopia or utopia is seen as a
dismissal of the problems that we
currently have i think that is a an
incorrect mindset
um and
like having kids just makes me want to
imagine amazing futures that like
maybe
i won't be able to build but they will
be able to build if they want to
you